among the economists what extent is
there a consensus that the house is on
fire in terms of how Greta uses it so
we're kind of - basically it's in
trouble I mean the problem is that
there's this if the question is amongst
economists mm-hmm
there's a lot of kind of introspection
about economic theory where it's gone
wrong and there's a movement really
about rethinking economics and there's a
bit of a danger there because economists
love to show how mathematical and
scientific they are compared to you know
the sociologists and the steel right and
and and so unfortunately part of the
rethinking economics movement has kind
of bought into that and is trying to
make economics more user-friendly you
know the ideas there's too much math we
need to make it much more about kind of
real life and the problem is that it's
not too much math it's the wrong math
it's math from Newtonian physics and
it's all about you know equilibria and
unique equilibria and averages matter
and the representative agent there was
all sorts of other mathematical tools
that could have been used for example
from biology in fact lots of the
agent-based modeling today but that's
kind of ghettoized and economics it's
not out there at the center uses more
kind of metaphors and and mathematics
from biology but also my thesis actually
was using a replicator dynamics oh yeah
you know distance from mean dynamics in
economics we assume averages so if you
you know in biology you couldn't explain
change if everyone looked the same right
distance from me and you show your
growth by how different you are from me
how different your fitness is and yet
this focus on averages and
representative actors in economics is
fundamentally different from how you
know growth and change just looked at in
other sciences and so I think what's
really important and this is what I
guess I was trying to do also in the
book is to kind of to debunk the
assumptions underlying the models versus
to say you know get rid of the math but
in terms of the house being on fire with
climate change unfortunately and this is
my point about just seeing it as
patching up different types of market
failures it's not that we don't need the
carbon tax of course we need carbon
taxes but
you know not really seeing the green
transition and the green revolution
that's required as an active market
co-creation and market shaping process
across that whole system is a lost
opportunity we should remember that big
revolutions in the previous waves of
technology for example mass production
would never have had the effect that
they did across the whole economy
without also really bold demand side
policies so suburbanization was
fundamental to the power of mass
production to really affect production
distribution consumption and
productivity and what we need today is
the equivalent of these kind of demand
side policies like suburbanization but
in a green direction and we're not
really getting except in some isolated
cases